the promotion and protection of the
rights of the child is a priority for
the eu
every child should enjoy the same rights
and live free from discrimination and
exclusion
in march the commission put forward the
first ever comprehensive eu strategy on
the rights of the child
the aim is to address the challenges and
better protect promote and fulfill
children's rights
the eu also upholds inclusion and
equality for children through the gender
equality strategy the disability rights
strategy the eu anti-racism action plan
the roma strategic framework
and the lgbtiq equality strategy
all eu member states are parties to the
un convention on the rights of the child
and one of the most important children's
rights in this convention is the right
to play
play is also one of the most distinctive
features of childhood since the very
early years
whether playing alone or with others
children learn develop skills and
integrate values through play
it is essential for their development
health well-being and inclusion
it also encourages kids to uphold
diversity and inclusion and respect one
another whatever the gender race
disability social status or religion
nothing should hinder the right of
children to enjoy play in its diversity
stereotyping on different personal
characteristics and strong gender
differentiation still exist
views of how a girl and the boy should
play
and the toys that are perceived suitable
for them maintain the traditional gender
role divisions in society
also games are not always accessible for
children with disabilities and not
inclusive enough of different racial
backgrounds and other diversity
characteristics
everyone in society has a role in
fighting against discrimination and
ensuring equality in play
from parents guardians educators the
media and children themselves
all the way to producers and
manufacturers of games and toys
you can contribute positively to
children's lives and futures
by producing toys which are inclusive
and promote diversity and contributing
to greater cohesion since the first
years in life
you can also combat gender stereotypes
by moving away from gendered design
packaging and marketing
the play for change awards provide a
great opportunity to show that this is
achievable
and that it benefits not only children
but our societies too
i encourage you to register online and
find out the winners and the final
ceremony of the eu product safety award
taking place on the 28th of september
this year the eu is rewarding businesses
that went the extra mile to protect
vulnerable consumers and we all know how
vulnerable children are